VOTE THAT DID IT.
>> Laura: AND WE ARE HAPPY THAT
KEVIN KIELY IS JOINING US NOW
FROM CALIFORNIA.
KEVIN, APPARENTLY AP HAS STILL
NOT OFFICIALLY CALLED THIS RACE
BUT IT IS A DONE DEAL.
YOUR REACTION TONIGHT TO BEING
LUCKY NUMBER 218.
I'M SO THRILLED ABOUT THIS.
>> THANKS LAURA.
IT'S BEEN CALLED BY THE DECISION
DESK SO VERY EXCITED TO COME IN
AND PUSH US OVER INTO THE
MAJORITY AND BRING SOME NEW
LEADERSHIP THAT IS GREATLY
NEEDED IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES IS
THE PART OF OUR GOVERNMENT THAT
IS MOST RESPONSIVE TO PUBLIC
OPINION.
THAT'S THE WAY OUR FRAMERS
DESIGNED IT THE WAY OUR
CONSTITUTION IS DESIGNED.
SO BY ELECTING A I KNEW MAJORITY
IN THE HOUSE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE SAID WE NEED CHANGE AND I'M
EXCITED TO GET TO WORK WITH THE
NEW MAJORITY TO DELIVER THAT
CHANGE YOU'LL BE SHOCKED TO KNOW
ERIC SWALWELL ANOTHER CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSMAN HAD A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT TAKE ON THE MIDTERMS.
>> THE VOTERS CLEARLY REJECTED
CHAOS AND THAT'S WHAT IF
REPUBLICANS RAN ON, AND THEY
AWARDED COMPETENCE AND WE RAN ON
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, THE
CHIPS ACT, THE RESCUE PLAN, AND
THAT FRAME WORKED IN OUR
DIRECTION.
IT WAS REALLY A WIN FOR
DEMOCRACY.
>> Laura: SEXUAL WELL'S USING
THE SAME LINE ASTHMA CON ABOUT
THINGSMENT KEVIN, YOUR RESPONSE
TO THAT.
>> WELL, NO, I MEAN, CLEARLY
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THERE ARE
RECORD LEVELS OF DISSATISFACTION
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ECONOMY, WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ABSOLUTELY OPEN BORDER, WHEN IT
COMES TO RISING CRIME ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY AND ASSAULT ON
PARENTAL RIGHTS.
AMERICANS ARE REGISTERING LEVELS
OF DISSATISFACTION WE HAVE NOT
SEEN SO BY ELECTING A REPUBLICAN
HOUSE THEY HAVE SENT A SIGNAL.
SO I THINK NOW WHEN YOU HAVE A
DEMOCRAT LED SENATE AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ADMINISTRATION IN CONTROL OF THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IS NOW THE
VEHICLE FOR EFFECTUATING THAT
CHANGE.
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IS, YOU
KNOW, GET INTO IT RIGHT AWAY,
GET INFLATION UNDER CONTROL, GET
CRIME UNDER CONTROL AND TO USE
THE OVERSIGHT POWERS THE
SUBPOENA POWERS THE ABILITY TO
QUESTION MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GET TO THE
BACKS WE'RE PUTTING THAT TO USE
IMMEDIATELY WHICH NANCY PELOSI'S
CONGRESS HAS STEADFASTLY
REFUSEDED TO DO THE LAST TWO